this is a country a medical community in
a state of trauma but one of the six new
designated COBIT hospitals in Rome
they're taking no risks were ushered
into a lift only two allowed at once
feels overworked already the Health
Director arriving in a separate lift to
show us to intensive care for many staff
the mental torment is worse than the
physical pressure of this crisis as they
fight to keep patients alive they carry
a fear their own exposure to the virus
at least 80 doctors and 21 nurses have
now lost their lives to covered 19 in
Italy two more nurses have died from
suicide it's your duty as they grieve
the colleagues they've lost they're
working to compensate for those in
quarantine here in Brescia Lombardi more
than 300 staff in this hospital alone
who have tested positive through kovin
19 precious new beds and intensive care
lay empty due to a lack of healthy
medics director of infectious diseases
unit there describe to us the impact of
living with the fear of contagion
we came to ask the Public Health
Institute just why so many frontline
staff have died and become infected when
you have what we call aerosol generating
procedures so when we were assist
patients and a disease that is normally
transmitted through large droplets
becomes transmitted through the air so
it spreads much much wider and of course
the people who are more exposed to that
other people who are at closer contact
with patients and are involved in those
medical procedures the situation was
discovered when it was already a large
issue with protective equipment for
hospitals staff is now a top priority
but there's still a shortage of masks
for gp's in Italy generations of medics
risking their lives to work in
circumstances they may never have
imagined
Sally Lockwood Sky News Rome